مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه وفيها نناقش الازمه الانسانيه في
شمال قطاع غزه التي بلغت مراحل غير مسبوقه
وباتت المجاعه واقعا في ظل ظروف ماساويه
يعيشها السكان لمناقشه هذا الملف سيكون
معنا من دير البلح المدير العام للمكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي الاستاذ اسماعيل ثوابته
قبل المقابله نشير في البدايه الى ما
اعلنته وزاره الصحه في غزه بان عدد
الشهداء ارتفع الى
2525 منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي في حين
بلغ عدد الجرحى
3000 منذ بدايه العدوان واشارت الوزاره
الى ان
70% من ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه اطفال
ونساء كما قال المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي
ان هناك 7000 مفقود تحت الانقاض او مصيرهم
مجهول كما قالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان نحو
مليون
و900 الف نازح يتعرضون للمجاعه وانتشار
الاوبئه والامراض المعديه بينما يتعرض
اكثر من 900 ال طفل في مراكز الايواء
لمخاطر البرد الشديد والجفاف وسوء غذيه
والامراض التنفسيه وايضا الجلديه هناك
ايضا 50 ال امراه حامل تعاني من سوء
التغذيه والمضاعفات الصحيه اضافه الى
400000 مصاب بالامراض المعديه نتيجه
النزوح في هذا التقرير نستمع الى شهادات
بعض النازحين في مدارس للواء كمدرسه تعوني
الحرث اني شماليه القطاع حيث يشكو الجميع
انقطاع المواد الغذائيه ومياه الشرب حتى
الملوثه
منها طلعنا من بلادنا تجج من بيت حنون
تردونا من بيت حنون هدود هد هد بيوتنا
سكنا مدرسه الح الثاني هنا قعدنا شهرين
ونص اجعنا دمروا المدرسه علينا اسر اثنين
اسر خذوهم وابن الثالثه ك مرمي جريح والله
في رجله اخوه برجله هذا احنا مهجين حدق مش
لاقين حبد الطحين ننا نعجنها اقسم لك
بالله وضعنا صار زي الزفت الله يفرج علينا
يا رب على كل متضايق وتحل على خير وسلامه
يا رب بنا والله بنا والله العظيم فكوا
اسرانا يما وروحوا دورهم روح على دورنا
وساعدونا والله العظيم ما عننا حبه طحم
بقوللك سلام عليكم كيف حالكم انتم احنا في
وضع سيء بدنا الامان وبدنا استقرار في
بيوتنا وبعدين احنا قاعدين يعني تنقلنا
100 خمس مناقل من حفصه من ه من هنا كل ه
وه قاعدين في بيت محروق والله صف محروق
وعن عزوز كبير 85 سنه عمرها مش قادر حتى
انكسرت اتلها وبتها كروسي كمان ودور دمروه
رحنا لقينا الدور كله ممسحات مسح الوطا
ايش ب نعمل ايش ب نسوي يا ربي يا رب حل
علينا يا رب اطلعنا بس اطلعنا يا رب الحمد
لله علمنا الله الحمد لله احسن اولادنا
سردوا ولادنا تكتل وماتوا ودون ما انهدت
علينا شش نسوي قاعدين في الخيمه صف خربان
ونا مش عندنا ولا واحد
عننا وجيت هنا على مدارس ابو زيتون وكان
معاي اللي هو ثلاث بنات
وولدين وجيت هنا وظليت عند ابو زيتون في
مدارس ابو زيتون وقعد يحكوا عنا الجيش
يعني اطلعوا على على جباليه البلد وجيت
انا هان واللي بنتين وولد استشهدوا ه
في
المدارسه يعني واحنا بنعاني في معناه
شديده
وم عارف شو اقول لك انا يعني الوضع عندنا
سيء كثير من ناحيه الميه ومن ناحيه
الكهرباء ومن ناحيه الطحين وزي ما انتم
شايفين وضع زي الزفت ماساء
جدا لا اكل ولا شرب ولا
ادويه اللي بتصوب بموت ما في ادويه ولا
ميه حتى
نشرب من واقع الماساه اذا شهادات مؤلمه من
غزه معنا الان اسماعيل الثوابت المدير
العام للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي استاذ
اسماعيل استمعنا ايذا الى هذه الشهادات
المؤلمه من المؤلم ايضا ان نعلم اليوم بان
الكثير من السكان قطاع غزه في مراكز
الاواء او في غيرها يقومون بطحن علف الحيو
حانات لاستبدال الدقيق الى اين وصلت
الامور فيما يتعلق بسوء التغذيه ودق نقوس
الخطر من الوصول الى مجاعه في
القطاع نعم ازدهار يعني دعيني ابدا من حيث
انتهيتي فعلا حتى في محافظه شمال قطاع غزه
حتى علف الدواب الذي يقدم الى الحيوانات
كان المواطنين الفلسطينيين وابناء شعبنا
الفلسطيني في محافظه شمال غزه يقومون بطحن
هذه الاعلاف
التابعه التي مخصصه للحيوانات لكي ياكلوها
ايضا نفذت هذه الاعلاف للاسف الشديد والان
باتت منطقه شمال قطاع غزه تعيش مجاعه
حقيقيه استقبلنا اكثر من 30 مناشده منذ
امس حتى اليوم اكثر من 30 مناشده من اهالي
شمال قطاع غزه اكدوا لنا ان منطقه شمال
قطاع غزه تعيش مجاعه حقيقيه خاصه في نقص
الطحين الدقيق بكل مشتقاته سواء كان من
القبح او من الذره او من الشعير وايضا
انتهاء تماما من كميات الارز المخصصه ايضا
التي كانوا يتناولونها بديلا عن الطحين
خلال الايام الماضيه اضافه الى نفاد كميات
المعلبات الخاصه بطعام ابناء شعبنا
الفلسطيني وبالتالي نستطيع القول بالامس
ان شمال قطاع غزه عمليا دخلت مرحله مجاعه
وبالتالي نحن نحمل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
كامل المسؤوليه اضافه الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي عن هذه
الجريمه جريمه ضد القانون الدولي وضد
القانون الدولي الانساني وكذلك ضد كل
الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات الدوليه نتيجه
استمرار حرب الاباده الجماعيه التي يشنها
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ونحمل الرئيس
بايدن شخصيا ايضا لان اي هم من اعطوا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الضوء الاخضر في
الاستمرار في هذه الحرب بل ومنعوا ايقاف
هذه الحرب من خلال وقف قرار مجلس الامن
الدولي لذلك نحن نقول ان الوضع الانساني
في قطاع غزه بشكل عام هو وضع متردي وكارثي
ودخل مرحله الكارثيه من منذ زمن بعيد
وايضا في شمال قطاع غزه على وجه الخصوص
دخل مرحله كارثيه الى ابعد الحدود
وبدا في ظل استاذ اسماعيل غياب اي افق لاي
هدنه في المدى القريب او وقف لاطلاق النار
تبقى الانظار متوجهه نحو المساعدات
الشحيحه والمحدوده اعلى وعسى ان تساعد في
هذه المرحله الصعبه ضعنا في صوره هذه
المساعدات اليات التوز والى اي مدى تسد
ولو جزء بسيط من احتياجات
الناس نعم نعم يعني فيما يتعلق بموضوع
المساعدات يعني دعيني اقول للاسف الشديد
هناك مئات الاف الاطنان متكدس على الجانب
الاخر من المعبر من من الجهه الجانب
المصري هذه المساعدات متكدس مئات الاطنان
ولا يدخل الى قطاع غزه سوى سوى كميات
بسيطه جدا لحاجه السكان لا تكاد تكفي هذه
المساعدات التي تدخل حتى حتى هذه اللحظه
سوى الى 5% فقط من حاجه السكان واذا ما
تحدثنا عن وصول هذه المساعدات الى ابناء
شعبنا الفلسطيني فاننا نتحدث عن وصولها
الى محافظات الوسطى وخانيونس ورافع فقط
اما جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فيمنع ادخال
هذه المساعدات التي اصلا مساعدات قليله
يمنع ادخالها الى محافظه غزه ومحافظه شمال
غزه وهذا ما يعمل على تازم الواقع
الانساني بشكل كبير جدا فهناك محاولات ل
ادخال المساعدات الى محافظه غزه ومحافظه
الشمال لكن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان
يطلق النار بشكل مستمر على كل من يحاول
الدخول الى هاتين المحافظتين ويحاول ادخال
المساعدات الى المواطنين وهناك اكثر من 38
شهيد استشهدوا نتيجه حصولهم او محاولاتهم
للحصول على المساعدات التي يحاولون
ادخالها الى محافظه غزه والشمال شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من دير البلح المدير العام
للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي اسماعيل الثوابت
والموضوع لا يتعلق فقط بسوء التغذيه ودق
نقوس الخطر من اي مجاعه قد تلحق بالسكان
هناك امور كثيره ومعقده وصعبه يعيشها سكان
القطاع شكرا جزيلا لك وصلنا اذا الى ختام
هذه النافذه الانسانيه الى اللقاء